entonces que tenemos aquí bueno esto es
una molécula de agua y de este lado
vamos a ver contamos con 12 3 átomos de
carbono en nuestra cadena más larga por
lo que sería met
pero tenemos únicamente enlaces simples
aquí por lo que esto es propano voy a
escribir eso esto es propano y luego en
el carbono número 2 tengo tanto un grupo
metilo como un bromo si los ponemos en
orden alfabético bromo va antes de
metilo así que voy a escribir esto como
2 bromo 2 bromo 2002 metilo propano
así que este es el nombre de esta
molécula que tenemos por aquí
ahora vamos a imaginar que está flotando
en un poco de agua y tengo una molécula
de agua por aquí vamos a imaginar que
tenemos este promo de aquí que es una
especie neutra y es neutral debido a que
tiene 7 electrones de valencia 12
y tiene la mitad de este enlace que está
compuesto de dos electrones y eso es lo
que está manteniendo el bromo neutro
pero sabemos que el bromo no es
completamente inestable si quisiera
tomar un electrón eso haría que tuviera
8 electrones de valencia y sabemos que
el bromo es más electro negativo que el
carbono lo que significa que cuando
están compartiendo los electrones en un
enlace es más probable que el bromo se
quede con los electrones del enlace a
que se los quede el carbono así que
imaginemos un escenario en el que el
bromo toma 2 electrones de este enlace
de aquí y esto no va a ocurrir super
rápido porque esta molécula por aquí el
2 bromo 2 metil propano es en realidad
razonablemente estable así que no estoy
diciendo que esto sucederá de manera
automática no es algo que ocurra muy
rápido pero podría suceder entonces para
mostrar que esto no va a ser una
reacción en un solo sentido
mostrar que es un equilibrio así que voy
a dibujar dos flechas de esta manera y
así una vez que esto sucede el bromo se
convertirá en una unión bromuro así que
voy a dibujarlo de este lado este es el
año en bromuro y va a tener 12
456 y también los dos electrones de este
enlace con el carbono
ambos electrones de ese enlace y ahora
tiene una carga formal negativa ahora
bien si eso ocurriera que le pasaría a
esta molécula de aquí la podríamos
llamar la molécula a la que el bromo
estaba unido vamos a dibujarlo así que
tenemos este carbono nuestro carbono
número 2
tenemos ch 3 justo aquí y tenemos otro
ch 3 por acá y luego tenemos este grupo
metilo en color azul
voy a dibujar al grupo metilo en azul
por aquí y lo estoy dibujando de esta
forma para indicar que el grupo metilo
se sale de la página hacia nosotros esta
cuña indica que está viniendo hacia
nosotros y ahora cuál va a ser su carga
acaba de donar la mitad de este enlace
que es equivalente a la carga
un electrón así que simplemente donde un
electrón por lo que esto va a tener una
carga positiva esto va a tener una carga
positiva
y aún carbono cargado positivamente se
le llama kart vocación así que este de
aquí es un kart vocación cargado
positivamente y la razón por la que no
es una locura pensar que esto pueda
suceder es que este es un carbono
terciario lo que significa que está
unido a otros tres carbonos 1 2 3
y un carbono terciario una manera de
pensar en ello es que esta carga
positiva puede ser compartida con los
otros carbonos un poco más así que un
kart vocación terciario es más estable
que un kart vocación secundario y
definitivamente más estable que un kart
vocativo en primaria un kart boca tienen
secundario sería si sólo estuviera unido
a dos átomos de carbono pero este es un
kart vocación terciario así que déjenme
escribirlo aquí este es un kart vocación
terciario este carbono está conectado a
otros tres carbonos de ahí que se le
llame terciario así que una vez más si
puede suceder no estoy diciendo que esta
reacción vaya a darse rápidamente en esa
dirección es por eso que dibuje aquí
estas flechas de equilibrio ahora vamos
a añadir agua a esta reacción así que
aquí tenemos al agua y como sabes el
agua es neutra sin embargo el extremo de
la molécula que tiene el oxígeno tiene
una carga parcial negativa como ya hemos
visto antes debido a que el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo que los
hidrógenos tenemos una carga parcial
negativa en el lado del oxígeno y una
carga parcial positiva en el lado de los
hidrógenos entonces tenemos este carbó
catión que es positivo y de este lado
tenemos una carga parcial negativa así
que te puedes imaginar que esta molécula
podría sentirse atraída a este núcleo no
va a sentirse tan atraída como lo sería
por ejemplo una unión hidróxido una
unión hidróxido tiene una carga negativa
completa aquí sólo tenemos una carga
parcial negativa
pero aún podría ser atraído a algo muy
positivo como este kart vocación así que
en esta situación la molécula de agua es
un núcleo filo débil lo escribiré de
este lado
la molécula de agua es un núcleo filo
débil no es tan fuerte como una unión
hidróxido que tiene una carga negativa
completa pero si se encuentra con algo
positivo como esté carbó catean y chocan
de la manera correcta te puedes imaginar
que uno de estos pares de electrones en
este oxígeno se iría hacia acá y
formaría un enlace con este carbono
haciendo que este carbono sea ahora
neutro y esto ocurre mucho más rápido
así que no voy a dibujar esta flecha
como una flecha de equilibrio esto
podría suceder así de este lado tenemos
a nuestro a nyon bromuro voy a dibujar
alan jon bromuro de este lado con sus 8
electrones y una carga formal negativa y
ahora voy a dibujar todo lo demás así
que tenemos este carbono tenemos este
otro carbono que va hacia atrás
de h3 aquí está el carbono en la parte
superior de h3 y tenemos este carbono en
el frente así ch3 y ahora mi molécula de
agua se ha unido al carbono así que
estos dos electrones se podría decir que
han atacado al carbono
ahora forman un enlace con el carbono
así que estos son los dos electrones en
este enlace covalente y ahora vamos a
dibujar el resto de la molécula así que
tenemos el oxígeno tenemos estos dos
electrones por aquí estos dos electrones
de valencia y por aquí está un hidrógeno
y luego otro hidrógeno y ahora cuál va a
ser la carga en este oxígeno bueno tenía
una carga parcial negativa debido a que
es más electro negativo pero ahora está
compartiendo un par de electrones con el
carbono lo que es equivalente a donar
uno de sus electrones por lo que ahora
este oxígeno tiene una carga positiva
así que te podrías imaginar que tal vez
otra molécula de agua se presente por
aquí permítanme dibujar otra molécula de
agua por aquí estamos flotando en el
agua así que hay un montón de moléculas
de agua
así que otra molécula de agua podría
venir aquí tenemos esta carga positiva y
el oxígeno estaba acaparando los
electrones en estos enlaces un poco más
que los átomos de hidrógeno sobre todo
ahora que está cargado positivamente así
que esta molécula de agua podría dar su
par de electrones a un protón de
hidrógeno y entonces este enlace con el
hidrógeno se iría con el oxígeno
electrón negatividad significa que si
este átomo es más electro negativo que
éste entonces si se rompe un enlace el
par de electrones que formaban ese
enlace es más probable que se vayan con
el átomo más electro negativo muy bien
entonces cómo se verá esto ahora vamos a
dibujar una flecha así voy a dibujar mi
molécula principal tenemos este carbono
que está unido a este otro carbono de
arriba y también estaba unido a otro
carbono por aquí
tenemos nuestro carbono que va hacia el
frente tenemos nuestro carbono aquí al
frente así tenemos el enlace con nuestro
oxígeno así que aquí está nuestro enlace
con el oxígeno justo ahí tenemos este
enlace con un hidrógeno este par de
electrones y ahora se ha quedado con
este otro par se ha quedado con este par
de electrones que estaba formando un
enlace con el hidrógeno así que este
oxígeno ahora es neutro antes será
positivo por aquí sólo tenía la mitad de
este enlace ya que estaba compartiendo
los electrones por lo que sólo tenía un
electrón es decir sólo tenía el
equivalente a una carga negativa ahora
tiene los dos electrones que formaban el
enlace así que ahora esta molécula es
neutra y ahora esta molécula por aquí se
convierte en un cat ión hidronew
permítanme dibujarlo así que ahora
tenemos esta molécula de agua
muy bien con sus dos hidrógenos justo
ahí con sus pares de electrones aquí
arriba y ahora está compartiendo este
par de electrones con un protón de
hidrógeno con este hidrógeno de aquí y
ahora esto tendrá una carga positiva
este es un hidro nea este es un catión
hidronew tal vez esté ión choca con otra
molécula de agua y ocurre lo mismo una y
otra vez y por supuesto no podemos
olvidar a nuestro a nyon bromuro así que
aquí está nuestro año en bromuro con su
carga negativa
muy bien ahora que nos queda pues
tenemos este camión y drone ya que tiene
una carga positiva tenemos este año
bromuro y ahora cuál es el nombre de
esta molécula entraremos en más detalle
en el futuro pero ahora se tiene un
grupo hidroxilo unido a la cadena
principal de carbonos tenemos un alcohol
entonces nuestra cadena principal de
carbonos tiene 123 carbonos esto nos
indica que debemos utilizar el prefijo
propio pero en vez de decir propano es
propanol así que vamos a escribir eso
este es pro
brock an
y podríamos dejarlo simplemente como
propanol en términos generales pero si
quisiéramos ser un poco más específicos
vemos que el grupo hidroxilo está unido
al carbono número 2 por lo que lo
llamamos propone' 2
y por supuesto todavía tenemos este
grupo metilo en color azul por lo que
podríamos decir que es 2 metil 2 metil
propano 2 ol
ahora vamos a pensar en cómo podemos
nombrar a esta reacción que acabamos de
ver bueno acabamos de sustituir un grupo
bromo con un grupo hidroxilo así que
creo que es razonable decir que esta va
a ser una reacción de sustitución
sustitución
y realizamos la sustitución con un
núcleo filo que aunque haya sido un
núcleo filo débil es un núcleo filo de
cualquier modo así que utilizamos un
núcleo filo núcleo filo pero aquí a
diferencia en la reacción sn 2 en el
paso determinante de la velocidad este
es el paso determinante de la velocidad
de la reacción este es el paso más lento
de la reacción
todo lo demás empezó a darse solo una
vez que ocurrió este paso este paso es
un equilibrio este es el paso
determinante de la velocidad de la
reacción y solo un reactivo está
involucrado en el paso determinante de
la velocidad
un reactivo
en el paso
en el paso determinante
de la velocidad
de la velocidad de la reacción
en este caso fue el bromo así que ya
puedes adivinar cómo vamos a llamar a
esta reacción es una sustitución en la
que participa un núcleo filo así que
sustitución núcleo física está en e
significa núcleo física y solo un
reactivo está involucrado en el paso
determinante de la velocidad de la
reacción así que esto de aquí toda esta
reacción que hemos dibujado es una
reacción sn 1